last night we'll and the cast of the new
live-action Disney remake of Aladdin
we're in Paris for a special screening
listen there is so much hype surrounding
this film but only ET can take you on a
magic carpet ride behind the scenes it
really was an extravaganza
you know Showtime as actors we felt
comfortable and confident to take shots
you really don't know who I am you get
to just have wild fun okay I can do that
some on set secrets its of 15 weeks to
build the fictional town of Agrabah
which is the size of two football fields
real jewels covered the walls of the
Cave of Wonders but the ones on the
floor were made of rubber so the cast
could walk on them and alladin sidekick
Abu is entirely digital we're trying to
stay truthful to the original but we
also wanted to give people something
different egyptian-born after mina
Massoud is Aladdin
Naomi Scott is Princess Jasmine and
there's a new character I played alia
Jasmine's best friend Naomi and I
immediately hit it off I mean we had so
much fun we would just cry laughing in
between tapes
backup boy I need some room to work
Aladdin is just one of those stories you
don't know how you know every word of
the songs you just do
[Music]
but the most epic musical number in the
film is when Aladdin enters Agrabah as
Prince Ali 250 dancers 200 extras and
that 30-foot camel flow took three weeks
to make with 37,000 flowers just fun on
set you know there's very few films that
have singing dancing drama comedy like
all of those elements but I love coming
to work every day
[Music]